if you've been decluttering for a while
and you've made progress but you still
find yourself asking why does my home
still look cluttered it may be because
you haven't addressed visual clutter
visual clutter is a sneaky little thing
because you don't notice it at first
glance or so you think your brain
definitely notices your subconscious is
constantly scanning the room for
information and it's so easy to have
overwhelm or chaos in other areas of our
life but our home is definitely an area
where I think most of us want to have
peace calm and just to feel good I think
there's definitely something to be said
about how when we feel good whether that
be because we're wearing clothes that we
actually like we have a good hair day or
we just finally have a clean room we
feel better about ourselves and then we
present a better version of ourselves to
whatever activity we're doing so I hope
that you find these tips helpful and if
you like these sort of videos I will
also soon be posting a video on
different ways that you can make your
home look cozy on a budget so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you won't miss when I post that video
or any of my other their videos on
minimalism and slow and intentional
living with all that being said let's
get on with the first one remove labels
now I'm not saying that you shouldn't
label things because labels can be super
helpful in order to help you have things
put back in their places if you have
kids or a husband that you just want to
put things back where they actually
belong and have a home labels can be a
great way to get this accomplished or if
you have people over and you want them
to actually help themselves to your
kitchen that can be super helpful in
order to keep things organized and in
their prospective locations so I'm not
talking about those kinds of labels the
labels that I'm talking about are things
that may already be on your packaged
materials like your soap dispenser your
shampoo bottle things like that that you
don't necessarily need a label for when
you go to a fancy upscale location you
will notice that their soap dispensers
do not have labels on them and that's
because Simplicity is visually appealing
to the eye so doing something as simple
as removing the label from your soap
dispenser can make it look so much nicer
a quick tip too if you you find yourself
removing a label and it just has that
sticky gunky residue on it Place rubbing
alcohol and it will just come right off
this was an old bottle of almond oil
that I had and it looks so fancy you
wouldn't even know this is just
basically a regular drugstore product
along the same lines of removing labels
off of purchased items is also removing
word signs or just paring down to a
select few I'm not gonna lie I actually
have word signs in the home because I
had a crazy chalk painting face where I
basically wanted to chalk paint
everything that I could get my hands on
so I made word signs for both of my
kiddos but besides that I've basically
removed all other word signs because
even though you might not think that
they add extra clutter to the home your
subconscious is constantly trying to
read these words so I would say it's
definitely okay to have some of them if
you want to be reading something
constantly because you like what it says
or you just really value that for some
reason but just pairing them down to a
select view can make a huge difference
and I've even gone so far as to remove
the labels off of my clothes hangers
because I had basically clothes hangers
from the store and even just popping
them off and taking them off made such a
huge difference in my closet that just
made it look so much more like a
boutique so find any areas in your home
where you see word signs or even just
letters or symbols and things like that
and you'll notice a huge difference this
next one is to put away frequently used
items I know it sounds counterintuitive
because you want to save time and you
want to be more efficient that if you're
going to use that coffee mug tomorrow
actually put it in the cabinet rather
than just leaving it out because clutter
attracts clutter it's so much easier to
just pile items on top of an already
messy pile and so this is what you're
trying to avoid by doing this is to just
put things back where they go it may
take just a few seconds more but it will
save you from having those piles add up
and this next one is similar to that but
it's to keep your counters clear there's
something about flat surfaces that are
just constantly trying to attract
clutter but again the more you stay on
top of this the easier it becomes and
then it just kind of becomes more of a
habit for you so if you just kind of get
in the habit of keeping your counters
clear once you've actually used them it
will be much more likely that it will
stay that way once you declutter more
you'll also find that you have more
space within your cabinets so you can
also store things that would normally be
on your countertop within your cabinets
so for example I have this knife rack
here that I can just keep within my
cabinet and then that way it keeps my
counter clear
use a color palette you definitely don't
have to have white walls like I do it
was something that I never thought I
would have I had like these bluish
grayish walls and I was crazy about them
I had them everywhere that we had lived
beforehand but I like the White Walls
you don't have to have that if you like
color that's that's awesome you could
definitely have pops of color in
different ways but use your colors
strategically that's something that I've
implemented into the decor in the home
I've also done it with my closet and
just different areas and I find that it
just all is much more cohesive and it
all just kind of matches together a
whole lot more and I definitely still
have color because I have this fuzzy
armchair that you would definitely not
find on the cover of a minimalist
magazine but again it it does have color
but it matches with my other colors and
so that it kind of Blends together so
find the colors that you like that you
would love to have in your home and it
will make things just look much more
cohesive also curate your paintings and
your artwork if you think about it when
you go to a museum someplace that wants
to showcase the art it'll just have a
whole bunch of paintings colored at all
all over the wall because that would be
difficult to appreciate that one
painting those details the landscape or
portrait or whatever it might be so for
example we have a very large painting
across from our bed my husband loves
this painting he actually saved it
because somebody was going to throw it
away he was so sad because as a painter
he can appreciate that somebody took so
much time to cook able to create this
the imagination that they had the
details that they put into it and he
appreciates this this is actually the
painting that we look at every single
morning as we wake up and if it had been
cluttered around with lots of other
paintings all around it we wouldn't be
able to appreciate its beauty because it
would be so much to look at distracting
from the one that we want to look at so
curate your paintings your artwork the
ones that are most meaningful to you
most special to you and it will make a
huge difference in making you just feel
happier I love this sex one is to get
rid of big bulky Furniture the reason
that I love this is because you can
declutter so many little items and it
doesn't really make a huge difference in
your visual side you just don't really
notice that much of a difference and so
you can kind of feel like I'm not making
progress with decluttering and
minimizing but if you get rid of a big
bulky item you will instantly notice a
difference previously we had a massive
four poster bed and we sold that one and
my husband and I built a new bed I
jumped up and down like a little kid
once he brought that in not only because
of the sentimental value because we
built it together but also because
removing that giant bed made our room
look so much more clear so much more
open light and cozy it made such a huge
difference that had we removed just a
bunch of little items it would not have
made such a noticeable difference number
eight is to find solutions for your
messy zones so for example paperwork of
course you might want to take an entire
day to actually declutter your paperwork
and digitize it and shred it and do
whatever it is that you need to do with
it if you find yourself constantly
tossing things in a particular area find
a solution for those things so for
example we have a mail holder so anytime
mail comes in of course we address it
but that's where it kind of goes
initially or our keys our keys whenever
we come in the home they get hung right
there the mud room is definitely an area
that would constantly get messy our
shoes would constantly be all over the
place there would be dirt and dust and
all sorts of things all over the floor
and so I basically because we had paired
down our shoes we had an extra shoe rack
that we no longer needed so I placed
that one in the mud room and now
everybody knows you just put your shoes
in the shoe rack and it looks so much
more clear the shoe rack also addressed
other messy zones for us so for example
we have chickens and our basket that we
used to carry eggs in would just always
kind of be scattered around the house
because it would be too much of a
nuisance for us to take it out bring it
back in so this is the spot that it
lives in and then because I homeschool
we end up with lots of artwork and then
this is just also an area where we drop
in cardboard boxes just random boxes
that we need to dispose of because we
use lots of bonfire so this gets
recycled in that way and so it addressed
our messy zones so that the chaos that
would have normally been all over the
floor now looks a little bit more
organized I'm certain that it would look
so much better if we had a nice pretty
little basket and some kind of pretty
box over there but you know what
sometimes you just gotta make do with
what you've got so think of those areas
that just commonly attract clutter in
your home and either use like a basket
or a rack or a box or something that
just kind of puts them out of the way
and makes them look organized number
nine is super simple is to hide cords
and wires either tie them together put
them behind another item or move them
around so that they're not visible for
example our router and all of our
internet stuff is stuffed under our sofa
so it's never visible but it's always
clear in an area where I can access it
very quickly should we need to reset or
do anything like that with it out of
sight out of mind number 10 is to use
baskets trays or bins so for example if
you love to have throw blankets but you
don't want them all over the floor or
all over your sofa have a basket for
them if there is a particular item that
you're constantly in need of a basket
can be a great way to reduce visual
clutter while also making it easy to
reach for number 11 is to keep your shoe
area tidy something that's helped us a
lot with this is to just have very few
shoes but we do take up our shoes inside
the home and if we just leave them
scattered it looks like a huge mess
versus if we just take the time to place
them in a line it looks so much better
now training my kids to actually do this
is the project that I'm currently
working on number 12 I kind of touched
on this when I talked about addressing
your messy areas but I wanted to speak
specifically about this one because it
might be your messy area and it's to
have a drop station for when entering
the home so for example we have added
hooks to our mud room so that whenever
we come in the home if we have a bag or
a backpack or whatever we need to hang
up that goes in there our keys have a
home they have a little hook where we
can place them in our mail has a home we
can place that in the little mail holder
so everything that we come in the home
with has an area where it's designated
to go you can also use a little tray for
keys but the key here is to have a key
no pun intended the key is to have a
home for all of of these items so that
you're never finding yourself wondering
where are my keys that never happens if
these items have a designated area for
them to go there
to remove or relocate refrigerator art
my kids love to make art but they know
that those front doors of that
refrigerator are not going to have
anything posted on them we actually have
the ability to put things on the side
because the side of the refrigerator is
exposed so if they make something it is
going to be alternated and we will have
one picture and then once they make a
new one that new picture will get posted
but it's not going to get cluttered up
with lots of different photos so they
basically have to pick their favorite
one and they can showcase that
alternatively you can just remove any
art or stuff that you have on your
refrigerator or find a different home
for them this next one is for my people
that have stairs a great way to make
sure that things actually get to where
they're supposed to go whether upstairs
or downstairs respectively is to have a
basket or a bin right beside the stairs
so this way the next time you go up you
can just take that bin with all the
stuff that belongs in the upstairs or
the downstairs so things actually get
put back in their respective places and
lastly number 15 is to make sure that
your floors are clear as a mom that has
two little kiddos that love to scatter
toys all over the floor I know that
nothing makes more of a difference than
making sure that my floors are clear and
this also goes towards things like
putting your clothes on the floor things
like that the more the piles on the
floor the more it attracts more mess but
it also just makes such a difference
because it makes your space look so much
more open and lastly for sticking to the
end I could not give you this one is to
have a designated bin or a basket or box
or whatever it is that you want to use
for items that are meant to leave your
home because you might think to yourself
why need to give this back to that
person or I need to declutter this item
but if you never actually go get that
item and relocate it in order to bring
your attention to that item chances are
it might not actually ever leave your
home so I have a designated basket for
any items that I know I need to
declutter and that way once it kind of
gets filled up I have to address it and
I have to either donate them sell them
give them back to their people whatever
it is that I need to do with them but
they need to leave so I think if we
could summarize all of these tips in one
it would probably be give your items a
home and if that home is somebody else's
then make sure to get those items there
that's it for today's video if you like
this video make sure to give it a thumbs
up and subscribe so you won't miss when
I post a new video and if there's any
particular videos that you would like to
see from me make sure to put it down in
the comments below or send me an email
until next time bye for now